Oh
My gosh, no loop no loop beat beat sorry my control my my
leverless controller was freaking out Sorry It was like I
plugged in my controller it was like beep beep beep beep
beep beep beep beep and I was like oh that's not good That
doesn't sound good.
I was like oh, okay, give me a sec.
Let me adjust this real quick I was just like oh why did it
sound?
sound like that oh no oh yeah it was gonna explode or
something also give me a sec i i'm a little bit all over the
place right now what else is new do keith what else what
else is new today um give me a sec i have to adjust some
stuff real quick uh sorry i just i got, I went, my sleep
schedule is a little messed up.
Oh, what else is new, Doki?
What else is new?
But I might have woke up at 5 p.m.
And I might have went to bed at like 9 a.m.
I found out when I woke up, I found out I would make more
money getting last place in the Overwatch tournament
But I'm putting more hours in the street fighting tournament
than I am at the Overwatch tournament I just found that out
I just found that out like when I woke up today It's just
like wait a minute wait a minute I put so many hours into my
wait a minute Wait it's don't get it's not about the money I
know but also the realization
welcome to the FGC the realization when I realized exactly
how many hours I put into this game um anyway yeah I'm doing
it for the love of the game guys for the love of the game
It's because you really, really want to die.
Okay, Mickey's like waiting for me right now.
But anyway, basically, okay, so I did a lot.
I played a lot of Street Fighter last night.
I played.
And I found out that in Platte, you might have seen me crash
out last night because I was crashing the fuck out last
night.
And I found out last night, um that you don't get win streak
bonuses until you get 10 wins in in plat and i was just like
basically normally you get 50 points per win and that is not
a lot of points it's not a lot of points so i was like when
does the win streak kick in when does it kick in and i was
like when And I was like, at five wins, I was like, surely
I'll have the win streak at six wins.
I was like, maybe this is it.
And it's still plus 50.
At seven, I was like, okay, this is getting a little crazy
here.
So then I got, I Googled and it was like, it doesn't start
until you hit 10 wins.
And you know what, and I died at nine wins.
I died at nine wins in a row.
And I was like, what's the point?
What the fuck is the point anymore?
So, I got to plat 2 and then I hit plat 2 and I was like,
I'm not strong enough for this.
I'm not strong enough.
It's basically to go up a tier, you need to get 20, 20 to 24
wins to go up a tier.
And it was definitely more than 20 games I played.
Why are we even here?
Also, I'm Faisy and I had a little bit of a crash out last
night as well because we found out um um so I basically if
we want to okay so basically we there was a there's a
beginner tier in another team that was a last minute
substitution um before the announcement obviously it was
before the teams were announced but they were substituting
someone that dropped out the day before the announcement and
the guy's a speed runner so like a little bit of
foreshadowing because I was just scoping out the competition
um and oh yeah no our beginner's fucked I'm sorry like
our beginners our beginner might be the lowest ranked out of
all the beginners in here um because I found out scoping out
the competition because I was like how much how much do I
Like, how much does it depend on me type of deal?
So, so, um, the speedrunner, um, won the enemy team.
Um, I looked at his VODs because I was like, by the way,
okay, so I looked at his, I looked at their profile and
they're higher rank than me.
And I was just like, how the fuck?
I'm a tier above beginner and one of the beginner who is the
beginning on one of the enemies team who is a speed runner
is a platform I believe maybe even higher because I bet
they're so I bet they're playing right now maybe they're
diamond by the by the time of the tournament I they might
diamond by the start of the tournament um and um yeah and i
was like how is this possible they started the game whenever
like you know we all started how is this possible like they
were last minute substitution i looked at his vods 12 plus
hours of street fighter every single day he has
200 matches within a week.
He has, do you know how that just, I thought I played a lot
for this.
I've only have 400 matches.
I only have 400 matches.
This guy who just started last week has 1,200 games for the
love of the game, for the fucking love.
I was telling Fel, you see, I was like, thank God this
year's tournament.
is this year's tournament is not to Japan.
It's like, Faisi, we might not get first place, but at least
they're not going to Japan.
At least it's...
Because the first place is money and also a trip to
somewhere in America, but at least it's not to Japan.
Yeah.
Yeah, and she was like, I would've been so mad.
She was like, I would've been so mad.
they're so they're so flat three don't i feel like they're
gonna be they might be like diamond by by the start of the
tournament all right yet at least they're not going to japan
that's good enough for me it's a florida man so so i was
just like oh my god
anyway um oh my gosh I know I woke up at 5 p.m.
because I was laughing shit I mean I I'd done like at least
three counter di's during the last 24 hours that's
improvement right yeah I put so many hours for just for for
this for this tournament in general and it just hit me that
like I'm making versus the Overwatch Tournament, which I've
had done a couple of games, but obviously I didn't put as
much time as I did here.
So I'm actually doing it for the love of the game, and also
to make it so that I don't look like I'm getting my ass
totally annihilated in my tier.
Even if I see was like, I don't know why they put you in
this tier, and I was just like, I was just, she was like, I
don't know why you're in that tier that you're in right now.
Like, it's not fair to you.
And I'm like, I was just like, am I that fucked?
Like, I'm thinking, oh, fuck, am I actually that fucked
right now?
I put so many hours, guys.
I put so many hours.
I literally coughing.
No one believes in here.
Anyway, I'm sorry.
Mickey's waiting right now.
For those who don't know, if you...
for those who don't know who uh mickey is um and uh he is um
one of the best my players in the world um so he has hit
like top five top ten within various international
tournaments like capcon cup and combo breaker and also um he
is the best street fighter player uh street fighter six
player Hong Kong and that's why I reached out to him because
I was like I'm from Hong Kong too and you're from Hong Kong
yeah I thought that would be a really cool stream um I
thought it would be a really cool stream and he's also on
Falcons at the moment um and but that's basically and he's
17 guys and he is he is a prodigy so um anyway when I asked
him if he could coach me he was like this would be the most
challenging thing he's ever done so i don't know if i'll
learn anything i don't i don't know i don't know if he can
fix me but you know at least like he tried you know at least
at least he tried and i remember uh when i was at capcom cup
and um uh one of capcom staff and feisty were telling me
about mickey because we you know we saw him on stage and he
they were like oh yeah he's like 17 and he's from hong kong
i was like oh my because one of those one of the stats are
one of the staff um at copcon um he is also from hong kong
and then he's like yeah i'm cheering for mickey because he's
from hong kong it's like wait you're from hong kong but i
didn't cheer for mickey too and then like we were like you
know we're like yeah mickey because i obviously i didn't
know like street fighter players a lot so then i was like
Like, oh my god, I had to cheer for him as well.
And then that's how I, like, knew about Mickey.
And then I didn't, I didn't, I was like, you know, I'm
playing Maya anyway.
So I was like, oh, I should, um, I should ask him to coach
me.
And then I'm glad he said yes.
Anyway, I'm going to go call him.
He, he's, he, I don't know how to expect.
I don't know what to expect for the stream.
Uh, but I'm going to call him now.
I don't know if he's watching right now and hearing me glaze
him.
So now he has big shoes to fill.
Yeah, same place.
Oh, it's fine.
It's not...
Oh, yeah.
By the way, I did ask Capcom if I can swear in the
tournament.
Because I remember I could swear.
I could swear in the...
I could swear last time.
But this time, they said that when our team is on stream, I
am not allowed to swear.
I'm not, they're like, please refrain from cursing when your
team is being streamed.
So I'm, as long as I'm off the main broadcast, I can let it
rip.
Okay.
So, but this time, this is like 8 p.m.
I'm not on an official channel or anything.
So I can, I can say fuck or whatever, because it's fine.
Like, where are you going?
This, I'm not on an official broadcast right now.
This is my personal hours.
This is my off hours.
I can say whatever the fuck I want to say.
Anyway, it's coaching time.
I'm sorry, Mickey.
If you're watching, Mickey, I'm sorry for making you wait.
Sorry, I had to do a little intro to everything and a little
bit of a life update.
But anyway, let's call Mickey right now.
Oh, no, he knows where she's going.
streaming i asked if he wants to be on stream and he also
retweeted the waiting room so i hope he knows oh hello hello
hello hello hello hello hey guys this is mickey the guy was
talking about does it sound good everything good all right
let me put you up on oh you're already on screen let me
adjust your thing real quick oh my gosh where are you on oh
there it is all right so everyone say hello to Mickey hello
hello chat would you like to do a little introduction I
already introduced you but you can do your own introduction
introductions yeah yeah yeah introduce yourself I'm the
biggest Mai in the century oh my god yeah he's the best Mai
in the world better than all the other Mai's out there and
he's also from Hong Kong guys same place Yeah, good.
I just, you know, this is fun fact.
I just know Doki is from Hong Kong.
It like used to be.
Yeah.
So I can speak, oh, so I can speak Cantonese to him.
So I might, someone might need to translate in case we do
speak Cantonese.
It's been, I've been, I've not gone to Cantonese, but I'm
like, I'm like, I'm saying English.
I've had shine coach me yesterday yesterday um and I'm
really bad at counter DI like you it's it's really really
bad it's I I would see someone like DI me and then I would
just look at them.
That's how bad it is.
Well, I mean, this tournament, DI is the most important
thing, I guess.
To counter it and use it, I think.
Yeah, yeah, I'm just really bad at it.
I've been trying to practice.
I've been trying to practice it.
But you want me to just rip off rank right now?
Yeah.
uh or you want to teach me something first before we rip off
rank uh because i don't actually know what exactly shine
teach you yesterday yeah uh but you know like before like
let's talk a little bit about my background i think yeah my
my morden is the one of the most hardest if you don't know
it's a morden like because like for modern although I didn't
play a lot but I got some research before it yeah like you
know every modern character got a auto combo yeah like
version medium version heavy version like like normally if a
good modern character like good for new players then their
auto combo combo like will just auto confirm it.
Like if you block it, like your auto combo won't come out.
But like if you hit it, like he will just confirm it.
But like my is like if you block it, it comes out and the
opponent punish you.
Yeah.
So that's why it's very hard.
Like and I think there's a lot of moves you need to like do
it yourself, cannot press it.
uh-huh so but like it's fine like just try try our best okay
uh so uh let's let's do some blow-up like can you do some
like uh drive impact reaction okay okay drive impact all
right all right yeah yeah yeah i set something up right here
for it okay it has jumps too i forgot about Oh shit, okay,
yeah, yeah, it's bad.
Okay, okay.
It's bad.
Yeah, good, good, good, good.
Yeah, good, good.
Yeah, good.
Yeah.
And yeah.
And you know, uh, how my level one perk is that like you got
some stock and you make your like everything stronger.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's very important like you spam it or like use it in
different ways.
Yeah.
It's just, I usually just throw it.
just throw the fads out like throw it but like yeah charges
I think charges is much better yeah you can and also like
yeah and also one back SP and also it's also very good like
that's kind of yeah yeah this one for walk walking is kind
of far and also like kick you had knocked your opponents
down but we can discover it later okay okay do you think you
can uh like i saw you your anti-air is very good yesterday
yeah a bit actually your dp entire very good i i'm only good
at anti-air because it's like pure reaction so it's like
it's easy but i don't know it says di it's like i'm pressing
So that's why like I have like other buttons buffered up,
which fucks with me a lot It is just something like I also
burn up very easily.
It's not I burn up very easily because I sometimes I don't
pay attention to my meter Yeah, this management of meter is
very hard thing so
But do you think like training was so boring?
Do you want to play Rake right now?
Oh, no, like, just call it.
I think for a new player, like, we didn't spend a lot of
time in this.
I think training was so boring.
Like, just barely reacting for one thing.
Yeah.
Like, you just watch your bot doing, like, 10 things, and
reacting one thing is so boring.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah.
Yeah, it is pretty...
pretty boring.
I just queue up rank and then I tab out.
Until I get in here.
The queue up rank is the better way for you to learn.
Yeah, it is for me.
Yeah.
You want to start it?
Start it?
I don't know.
All right.
I'm ready to start rank.
Let's go.
Yeah, I think you won't move out.
All right.
Where is it?
All right, there it is.
All right.
You're going to watch me get my ass kicked.
Yeah.
But it's okay.
Yeah, it's fine.
I think.
It's okay.
Maybe you say, you tell me that last time you tell me in
Twitter that you're Plat1 and you know I saw you.
Yeah, I'm Plat2 now!
Yeah!
Yeah, and it's hard.
It's so hard.
I'm gonna lose Plat2 for you.
You won't see me lose Plat2?
I don't really know.
I saw you.
range like end of range to end the stream yesterday no
you're mad on it wait what oh yeah no i was i was i'm very
passionate i'm passionate it's fine all right we can do this
I didn't warm up, so...
Oh, shit.
Yeah, spam your light auto.
It's very good.
Yeah, throw it.
Oh!
I'm burnt out.
Oh, what?
It's okay.
It's okay, right?
Yeah.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh, it's no longer okay.
It's no longer okay.
It's all right.
It's okay.
What the- What the- What the-
Oh.
Oh, I'm burnt out.
No!
I grabbed first!
It's fine, it's fine.
Oh, okay.
It's no longer fine.
Oh, I think she blocks that.
It's...
Wait, wait, we got...
Not a lot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh.
Oh, what?
Oh my god.
Yeah.
If you don't know what to do, like, just spam your SV.
Like, move your hand.
Oh my god.
I charged it.
Oh, no!
No!
Get out!
Right.
No!
It was not okay.
I don't fight Kimberly.
This is the first Kimberly I've ever fought.
I don't know her moves.
Get out!
Yeah, we'll cover it weird.
This is the first Kimbley I fought ever.
Oh, he's throw-looping me.
Okay, now I'm just panicking.
What is this move?
Oh, that's a bunch of weird moves.
Yeah, it's so weird.
Oh, God.
I just don't know how to counter DI.
please stop okay
oh no I'm on the other side now
okay no no he threw me um so yeah what do you think what do
you think Like, first of all, you don't know what the
character doing.
And yeah, screen to work something for the meter management.
Yeah.
Oh, I thought this game.
Watch one more.
Oh.
Cool.
Your connection is bad.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh shit!
Um, I'm burnt out.
Maybe bad.
Wait, he's burnt out too.
Oh.
Oh no.
Look, it's because he's one bar Wi-Fi.
Oh my god, he starts with DI!
Who starts with DI?
Some DI!
No...
He burns out so much!
He's bringing us faster than me!
Oh no, the fan!
You quit it.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, now that I know...
Every time, every fucking time!
I'm sorry!
I know he doesn't too!
That's the worst part!
I think I'm just panicking.
are you are you okay vicky are you are you okay i'm good i'm
just thinking i'll manage it better okay
oh my gosh of course you block it
oh no i spammed it
Please get away from me.
What?
Use your DI.
Use it.
Oh.
Yeah.
There we go.
Oh.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, we're getting there.
We're getting there.
Come on, use your DI.
Use your DI.
Yes, okay, I use my DI.
I use my DI.
I use mine.
Good.
Use magic.
No, I pressed it.
I swear to God, I pressed it.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, yes.
Okay, yes, yes, yes, I blocked.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, no.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, no, okay.
Yes, all right, there we go.
There we go.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm getting back into it.
And here we go.
Oh, really?
No, come on, Preston.
I couldn't get the little time.
There you go.
Okay, good, good.
Nope.
Oh, he...
Really?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Ah!
No!
Okay, we're still alive.
We're still alive.
No!
Okay, okay, I forgot about that.
Brok it.
It's Brock.
Okay.
Awesome!
There we go!
Yes!
Yeah, I got it!
I got the attire!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yeah!
oh my god i pressed it too
oh yes i counted i counted di i did i'm burnt out i'm burnt
out i'm burnt out fine fine he's burnt out too he's burnt
out too that's right dodge this There!
I did it!
There!
It's possible!
I'm just warming up.
I'm warming up.
Yeah, you're getting better.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Um...
So, let's talk it a bit.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let me say I can stop it in time.
All right.
So, like, the main problem?
Is that, like, the media management, of course?
Yeah, yeah.
So...
I want you to do, if you can, every knockdowns, you knock
your opponent down, you try to charge your special present.
Okay.
And like do do the things like.
Dash, if you can, let's try.
Let's try it first.
Charge friends, dash, heavy special.
one time okay oh press one time okay yeah yeah if you can
like you can try like that like press press it again and
press all like just like it comes out like that yeah yeah
and press it again okay yeah um and also like you can mix it
and like just dry rush flow dry rush i like you yeah yeah
and dry rush overhead that was overhead that's overhead the
four the four medium one okay that four four me Oh four and
medium this okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and the gouge the
the the minim special you can come boys yeah oh shit oh my
god
Yeah.
Oops.
Oh my god!
Yeah.
But like, always remember, if you can, like this is the same
with the OD fan and also the charge fan.
Yeah.
Like the function is the same, but like you save you some
meter.
Yeah.
So if you can like charge your best to use more, this one.
like do dry rush like do something to to make a pressure but
like not to use the the x1
all right also uh like it is like and also if you in in
corner yeah throw your opponents just dash out and throw it
again dash up and throw it again like yeah yeah no no just
Dash, dash, dash.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
It's a full loop.
All right.
Barely cannot do anything.
Dash up, throw it again.
And also mix it with light auto.
Like either you throw or you do the light auto.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Just make it still first.
Okay.
yeah either this one or that okay so uh yeah
all right so let's do these two things first remember when
you knock your opponents down you do charge fan and attack
and not like use less use less meter yeah yeah less the only
one yeah yeah okay and you know getting weaker like there's
a little slightly difference of like when you got getting a
fire stock with level one yeah yeah without it but like i
think it's fine yeah okay just also keep charge your fans
all right and also especially if you got stock if you can
like just like because you just also use your stock if
you're like using the normal fan yeah yeah yeah yeah so if
you can like just charge it more time like more way to
charge it rather than do the normal one all right then this
do this instead yeah okay yeah and like do your driver's
thing the driver's mix yeah okay do this and then yeah throw
and like also like the lights auto like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you just like even though you're panicking or what but
like you just remember this what you need to remember you
should do your things at least yeah yeah yeah all right all
right just stop panicking just stop yeah yeah yeah no no no
panicking is fine you show like you need to remember what
you should do But also remember.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, a Chun-Li.
Okay, that's someone I'm fighting.
Dude, I'm fighting a Chun-Li.
So it'll be good practice.
Please, Miss Chun-Li.
Let me rank up.
Oh.
Yep.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Yes, yes, yes.
Bro.
Blood.
Oh.
It's fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, I should just block that because she just wakes up on
it.
What?
No!
I already queued it up.
I'm panicking again!
No!
I'm pressing buttons, but I'm panicking.
Oh, she throws me back!
That is unfortunate, unfortunate.
Jesus!
Try to throw your opponents more if you can.
Yeah, don't wake up.
Oh, he always wakes up.
I keep forgetting that.
Yeah.
The next time, just block it.
Like, block it on break up.
Okay, I'm gonna block it.
Try to hit the bomb.
No!
I just... yeah, a little bit slow, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Broken, broken.
There you go!
Okay, put it!
Yeah, see, see it!
I think I learned!
I'm learning!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay.
Good, good, good, good.
We're in the good process.
Yeah!
Oh...
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Oh, he does do that.
Freaky, free.
React, what impact the forward.
No.
Ah.
No!
What?
That's fine.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Did I kill him?
I kill him?
I kill him.
I don't kill him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh,
oh, he quit.
Yay!
He quit on me!
I...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, if you can, like, try to throw more.
Okay.
And...
Like throw fan or throw?
Throw and dash up and throw.
Okay.
But if you miss green, just throw ones and charge your fans.
Okay, okay, okay.
Like, yeah, charge it.
Try to charge more to figure out the range.
Yes, yes, charge it.
Yep.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, it's okay, okay.
He walked back to her.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Okay, good.
Good.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
He does that.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Doff.
You need to stand to block that.
That was weird.
Okay, good, good, good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Touch it.
Oh my god!
Yeah, it's charging.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, oh, okay, okay, okay.
That's okay.
Okay.
Wait, what?
It's no longer okay.
Oh.
Okay.
It's no longer okay.
We're learning.
We're learning, we're learning.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's good.
You stop me.
Oh,
no.
Oh, I'm burnt out.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Childhood.
Okay.
Oh, no.
oh god that's good okay okay wait do i block it no i didn't
block it okay i was on my fan you're still alive fine oh
it's not fine any wait yes it's fine it's still fine it's
still fire
yeah oh no i got too cocky there
Oh, I dropped the combo.
I got too cocky.
No, get off of me.
Ah.
All right.
Round one.
Fight.
What?
Oh, he was too close.
Oh, my God.
Stop!
Please stop!
Oh geez!
I can't block it all!
Oh no!
What?
You didn't block it, you didn't block it.
Okay.
No!
Ah!
I don't have...
I can't even count it if I wanted to.
No.
Okay, so yeah.
Okay.
Stop it.
Um, so, uh, yeah, let's try to do three more things first.
Okay, okay.
So, um.
Um, like let's switch it in mid-screen.
Mid-screen.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, wait, what?
Yeah, switch it in mid-screen, mid-screen.
Oh, new screen?
Mid-screen, mid-screen, mid-screen.
Oh, you stream?
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, no, no, mid-screen.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Okay, fine.
It's fine.
Yeah, fine.
Oh, mid-screen.
Oh, okay, okay.
okay so so i'm sorry if my no it's okay you can speak to me
if you want to like if there's a word you don't know yeah so
when you're doing um the medium auto yeah so um dash up and
throw like you try to like feel the timing dash up and throw
medium auto okay yeah
throw it okay and also the heavy one okay try to both build
both like
this only comes out when you got level 3 but if you don't
like this one comes out so yeah like just try to throw more
okay like this is the important because if you like this
game you get get your meter back quicker when you win
offense like yeah we keep you attacking get more meter back
uh-huh and also
like you need to be careful of your meter if you like um
well let's say in this way you're getting less than two
gauge yeah you should start aware you were getting burnout
yeah like You can jump out, throw in your offense, charge
offense to get your offense back.
But if you're in corner, you are in very close range, so
better not.
Okay.
And also, if you're defensively, you can do the break up
reversal.
I don't know if you know it or not.
It's like pressing auto special.
this one and also auto special for for auto special it's
like OTP yeah this one is also another way to like get you
out like at least if your opponents do anything like throw
you press you you can getting it out but I think yeah also
the level one is perfect also yeah like it depends if you've
got a lot of gauge do it okay and also I want you to do one
more thing if you're in burnout your opponents impact you I
know it's very hard to react but like if you cannot react
just try to block it okay if you're not in honor okay block
it like at least like you don't stand it and getting hit
from it okay block it just block it first all right yeah uh
and also yeah yeah throw it more try to pull it more like
just try to press like not pressing that much like just
throw and mix it with the lights auto okay like just these
two things all right like just throw more auto yeah throw
more auto all right throw more and And if you think, like,
try to use more charge fan in far range.
Like, more far, like, yeah, your opponents won't get hit
you, like, in this range.
And you're safe to do those things.
And if you charge it, like, just your fan is stopped.
You can attack.
It's your round.
Okay.
Got it.
All right.
Yeah.
I understand.
Wait, like, let's do it step by step.
It's fine, it's fine.
Yeah, I can do this.
Learning, learning is learning.
I'm learning, yes.
All right, here we go.
Let's see if I remember everything.
I can't.
Yeah, just...
Yep.
Oh!
Okay, hello.
Yeah, charge it.
Yeah, Changa again.
Okay.
Um.
Yeah.
Yeah, throw it.
Oh, I thought he was...
Yeah, he did.
He did.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
It's fine, it's fine.
It's so fine.
Oh, okay, good, good, good.
It's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
Very fine.
Yep.
There we go.
Look, I'm throwing.
I'm throwing.
Throw it.
I'm throwing it.
Yes, yes.
Oh my god, and I jumped too!
Okay, okay, good.
Yes!
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Yes, I'm planning.
I'm figuring it out.
Yeah, very good.
Okay, okay, okay, I'm starting to believe!
I'm sorry!
Oh, wait, okay, nice.
He didn't block that.
He doesn't know.
Oh.
He doesn't let me grab anymore.
Oh, why don't you let me grab?
Oh, my God, my Bermuda.
My Bermuda.
Yeah, it's fine.
Okay.
Just keep attacking.
Yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Throw your hands.
Oh.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, he blocked it now.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, he'll start jumping.
Oh.
Why won't you let me grab?
Let me grab!
Ah.
Oh my god.
Oh my, what is...
Wait.
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh god, no, that's bad.
That's fine.
Oh god, no, that's fine.
Close, close.
Oh!
Okay.
Gotcha.
Oh, yeah.
No, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
I don't even know.
What did I do?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, good, good, good.
Yes!
Okay!
Okay, let's go, let's go, let's go!
Let's go!
Yeah.
I'm figuring it out.
all right we're going straight into another one yeah so if
you think um you cannot react to the impact yeah try try to
block it at least okay okay oh i throw him i threw him down
i threw him down that's almost that's almost like blocking
that's almost like blocking yeah
It's fine.
What?
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, good.
Okay, good,
good, good, good.
I played a little slower, but it's working though.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I didn't think he was already dashed.
Yeah.
Just like give it a friend.
Oh, no.
My fat.
Ah, okay, good, good, good.
Okay, that's fine.
Yeah, yeah, I burned out, but that's okay.
I got fire.
It's okay.
Yep.
Oh, he's getting closer.
No, no, don't put me back in there!
Don't put me back in there!
No!
No, no!
Well there you have, I think.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, no!
No!
I wanted to throw!
Okay.
All right.
I wanted to throw.
All right, I got the throw.
Good, good, good.
I got another throw?
Okay.
All right.
Oh!
I countered DI!
I'm burnt
out!
Okay, and then I throw him.
Okay, okay.
Yes!
I'm doing more throws!
You got better reactions.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're reacting!
Yep, yep, yep.
what up oh
no oh okay he messed up too he messed up oh what i didn't
okay yeah i'm a little bit okay oh i thought i blocked it is
it okay though is it okay though no i couldn't they couldn't
I tried, but I think I killed him.
I live!
Yes, we lived.
Oh no.
Can't wait.
Roll.
Throw.
Yes.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh no, not throw.
No, I wanted to counter.
Yeah, it's okay, okay.
Oh, I didn't mean to press.
I pressed twice accidentally.
No.
Yeah, it's fine, fine.
At least we lead, gotta meet the lead.
H lead.
No, I pressed it, I pressed it.
I swear.
Yeah.
This is bad.
This is really bad.
I think he blocks it.
Never mind.
This is really bad.
This is just...
No!
Oh, this is so bad.
This is so bad.
Alright.
Roll.
Yes!
Oh no!
Okay!
No!
Oh god, this is bad.
Oops!
Alright, take it slow, take it slow.
Okay.
Oh, never mind.
I took it a little too slow, I think.
Oh!
No, he jumped over me.
Oh my god, that's the first throw I've ever seen from him.
Oh, come on.
Oh, no, it's getting worse.
No.
All right, oof.
Okay, okay, yeah.
Reset, reset, reset.
Reset, reset, reset, reset.
We're resetting, Mickey.
We're resetting.
Throw.
Throw!
Okay, good, good, good.
Go,
go, go, go.
There you go.
Okay, good, good, good, good.
I'm remembering how to throw again.
Okay, he broke it this time.
Fuck.
Okay, good, good, good.
No!
All right.
slower.
Oh, he adapted to me.
Oh, of course he jumps now!
Okay, very good.
Let's stop it a bit.
Okay, okay.
So now our strategy is try to charge the fans and like just
do the pressure.
so when your opponent adopt it like they will like try to um
they will try to mostly jump and impact okay to like try to
kind of like anti it i don't know uh so um when you're not
doing these things um you're standing at the range to wait
them to do those things okay if you're not charging if
you're like starting like scared you cannot do it all time
because your opponent will get it one time then to get that
yeah and yeah and also like and also from also about throw
if you think your opponent start attack it like you jump
like yeah you jump and yeah give it a good damage okay and
also your opponent do the reversal and you block it so um
like i know it's hard but like you just keep it in mind if
you don't think your opponent might do those like or they do
very oftenly like just you know there you can jump and also
block it for those options yeah like it's like rock paper
scissors stick in yeah stick in the plan first do the usual
thing first and if your opponent does anything different
just do those things okay and also if you are in a range
like you in a corner you don't know what to do you can try
to do your special okay like in a weird situation like your
bonus is try to frost you in the corner and you're kind of
in the corner so you're scared you're scared pressing
anything so if you can you can try to throw your fence or do
the back back special this?
yeah this one this one like like this one is weird so it's
kind of far range is uh yeah it's kind of poke yeah you know
what's poke and um if like you said it if you open and hit
it with counter it will knock down okay so you can try to
escape and also um if you can like try to jump it out like
and also jump is also another options yeah uh charge plant
is also because like it's kind of close range with your
opponents you're probably panicking but like yeah bear in
mind you got those tools at least you use in when you're in
corner like trying to escape okay uh and also oh we mix one
more things yeah so um after throw um we can do dry rush
overhead yay what you're practicing yeah this one okay oh so
like but like it's only a hit like over it is the thing that
only hit when opponent is crouching yeah so we can mix those
thing yeah because you press and crouch your opponent need
to crouch to block it but if you overhead he crouch and he
hit and you got a good damage yeah okay so yeah just bam
remove and like yeah we just keep adding little little
things and yeah we're trying if you can do it little little
thing so we're sticking the path in plan so like charge fans
draw rush throw do your thing and also yeah if you can do it
like charge fan draw show for it you can try it but like I
didn't I barely see you to use this yeah kind of weird move
but like we can add it later but like step by step it's fine
yeah okay yeah i get it all right i'm ready step myself like
and this yeah this one um if you go stop it get even longer
the range is longer and more a bit
all right we got this oh my god i don't know her moves i
don't i don't know her moves six-game win streak it's okay
it's fine it's fine it's fine used to be a sick game victory
oh that's true that's true yep yep that's true you know what
oh what okay okay okay
throw right no no throw careful of your meter yeah
whoa okay
Throw it.
Oh, I try.
Okay, okay, okay.
No.
It's fine, it's fine.
What the fuck?
She bait jumps me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Charge your fan if you don't know what to do.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
Yep.
No!
She keeps backing up!
Good, you're good.
Catch, catch your fans.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wake up.
Yeah.
No, she won't let me grab.
No, I'm burnt out!
Yeah.
Get away from me.
Get away.
Yup.
Nope.
That blocked.
No.
That's fine.
You're locked and locked.
I'm alive.
And I'm being too aggressive.
No!
What?
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
No!
No, no, no, no.
Rocket!
Yes!
Okay!
Wait, I'm learning!
Nice,
nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Oh, what the fuck?
Where did I- It's too good, it's too fine.
Wait.
Oh!
I hit it!
Okay, good, good, good.
Patience.
Oh.
Oh, okay, good.
There.
I'm locked!
I'm locked, yes!
I did it!
I broke her win streak!
Jesus Christ, when does this combo end?
ends now
oh she's so aggressive jump more oh what the fuck the rocket
rocket reversal oh I tried the flag oh no no no round two
fight oh oh oh
Oh, I didn't mean press twice.
That was an accident.
No.
No!
She's so aggressive!
No, and she blocks it!
She lands!
Round one.
Fight!
Yeah.
Oh.
She baits me.
now she's so smart
yeah you give me space you go okay yeah try to go up yeah
no yes i'm trying oh i couldn't throw her you scared you
okay i threw her Oh, what?
No!
Oh, no, no!
Oh, I was too aggressive.
That was too aggressive.
No,
no, no, no, no.
I never see her DI.
Yeah, it's fine, it's fine.
it up yeah oh okay
ah let's try let's try ah oh we're both no that's fine Yeah.
Yeah.
No!
What?
Okay, that should hit her.
Close, close, close.
Okay.
No.
There.
Got her.
Okay.
Okay, go, go, go, go.
All right.
No.
Come again.
Yes, yes, yes.
She grasped me!
I grab a little bit.
There you go.
How does she grab me?
I'm mistimed.
Oh, okay.
That's how.
It's fine.
This is bad.
It's time to party.
No!
Wait, what?
No, I...
I thought... Drop it.
Drop it.
Okay.
It's fine, it's fine.
Okay, I'm a little scared.
No, come on, she won't let me push up.
She knows I'm scared, because I am scared.
We're friends, yes, try us.
Yeah.
Need to go for it slowly.
She knows.
No!
Oh, God!
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Throw it, throw it.
Shoot what?
God.
Throw it, throw it.
Okay.
Throw your fence.
Like she, I'm- I was wanting shots!
No, I didn't see the time!
I wasn't paying attention!
No, it's okay, it's okay.
I didn't realize it.
I was so scared.
So...
Let's see, to rank.
Let's stop it a bit, stop it a bit.
Okay, wait, wait, oh no, I...
I don't think I can.
Oh, it won't let me educate after this.
I didn't realize it was early time out.
Early time.
Crazy people.
At least I took their win.
A lot of players.
Yeah.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, no.
Oops.
That's a bunch of weird moves.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Get away from me!
Oh my god.
I should not have done that.
That might have been a bad idea.
Ah.
Okay, good, good, good.
No!
She threw me!
Unfortunately.
Oh.
No.
I didn't think I would hit that.
Wait.
No throw.
No more throw.
attacking
okay oh good good good I don't have bird it is so he's
attacking she's attacking a lot so oh no now I'm in the
corner that's not that's okay as long as I'm not in the
corner drop it okay good there you go okay good good good
Oh!
I'm doing good.
I don't have any more meters so I'm just gonna try it.
Try it.
Go for it.
Don't be scared.
Just try your best to go for it.
Yeah.
Oh.
No!
I didn't think he was- she was gonna jump.
What the- what the fuck?
Okay.
Oh, they did not mean to do that.
Oh, that was an accident.
But it's okay.
That's not okay.
No longer okay.
Use their life.
Go offense.
Okay.
Oh, good.
No!
He's got it before me!
I don't know what happened here.
The beam is a fireball.
Yeah.
And level one's...
by the fireball that's why i see oh he was crouching
ah i keep timing it up time it back yeah my timing for it is
so bad and then he grabs me back he did he yeah he tagged a
lot he drove he's scared i'll just throw the drum bar to
punch Okay.
Oh.
No!
He grabs more than me!
Don't!
Oh, I fucked it up.
I fucked it up.
I'm getting worse!
I'm getting...
Okay, okay, fine.
It's fine.
Reset, reset, reset, reset.
Reset, reset.
Oh, cool.
Oh my god, you bitch.
Okay.
Yeah.
No.
She's better at grabbing than me.
She is so good at grabbing.
That's it.
I'm grabbing you.
Oh,
what?
Oh.
Okay.
No.
I don't
know if that kills that doesn't kill no no i threw my set no
i
think it's cheap cheap cheap kills also i should have level
three yeah all right all right um so um wait if you uh so
let's do one more things yeah okay so yeah like yeah if you
charge your fans try to do dry wash what's that called dry
wash medium auto medium auto press one times and press it
again okay like so yeah it would be like it would be like
charging fans and the fans you press your first cross medium
punch and the fans drop and you press it again again you
understand okay yeah so wait wait yeah oh so you saw you
press it yeah quicker oh yeah because like you saw a lot of
uh just uh the eleanor he keeps smashing so you can do this
to like afford his smashing and punish him okay yeah and
also um this also work with no matter no matter the OD fans
or charge one it's same and also yeah so if he's managing
his job you can hit oh like that yeah like that like that
yeah okay and also you can also charge fans and jump jump
jump jump oh like no rush just jump oh just jump forward
jump forward yep like that like yeah close range you get hit
so you need to don't need to spend a brush and you can still
get a mix okay yep the only thing you're scared is that he
anti-air but because you got a balanced job the opponent is
scared and like it's mostly scared but like can mix with
those two you think opponents like only waiting for your
entire just wait okay also i think this this can avoid
impact also okay the opponent impact you jump and you punish
him okay so uh anything else let me think uh yeah so um if
you're in corner um you think you and your opponent in a
really close range yeah try try to jump jump forward like
just escape your corner okay just try to escape corner I
think this game corner is very scary when you're in corner
yeah you're like barely scared to do anything and also one
more one more thing I know it's hard but um try to if you
like got very less gauge try to do um heavy auto into
special okay like just heavy auto no come like just press
one time what like i mean just press one time and yeah yep
this one and and also mix it with charge okay like just like
press it heavy auto and charge Okay.
Let's charge it.
It's like, yeah.
This?
No, no, no.
Press it.
Press the special.
Hold it.
Oh, hold it.
Uh, no, no.
No auto.
Like, just only...
Like, yep.
Like this.
Oh, okay.
So you get some meter back and also you can get your
offense.
Okay.
Yep.
And after it's hit, uh...
uh do the crouch crouch uh do the medium auto and medium
also again like just what i talk yeah okay okay
yep oh whoops like that and also you can walk up to throw
like something like this uh-huh like like you after you
charge you can walk up throw walk up for all and like use
your turn oops and also you can jump whatever so and also if
you think your opponent will attack yeah you can try charge
fans like what usually is charge fans and you dry wash and
your opponent attack right yeah so you can try to do dry
wash and jump jump like jump forward oh yeah jump just jump
just jump and yeah yeah do a combo so okay let's try it uh
it's very hard to try um and actually because no because the
main thing is like we are in very bad connections yeah yeah
mode so um uh charge uh yeah or maybe we can try try a
training is bad okay okay let's just try it try which one uh
training more online training mode oh online training mode
oh oh custom room okay yeah custom room okay oh let me
invite you yeah yeah yeah mine's not dokey my
oh my god ultimate master you know I'm not a before the
coaching I never touch more than ever you know what age did
you start playing Street Fighter when did you start playing
since very young like what how old are you nine years old oh
like in classic Street Fighter Street Fighter 5 something
like wait And you were on Classic at 9?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god!
That's hard, you know?
So in 5, we got no more than like everything we need to like
try and figure out.
So, um, uh, so, okay.
Mujously, like, let's watch me to do one.
Okay.
So, charge fan, jump forward.
So, um, yeah.
We're gonna attack, like, try to do more early.
Okay.
Oh, whatever.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, no, no.
I'm gonna try again.
Oh my God, I don't want to, I don't want to run at you.
No!
Like, you don't need a profit.
Just jump.
You don't need a profit.
Okay.
I'm jumping.
I swear to God, I'm jumping.
sorry i jumped backwards because i got skewed yeah and also
because of bad oh i got it i got it so so you can also like
after jump like do a combo like auto combo or something okay
yeah yeah try again try again yep yeah good we're in good
process yeah yeah and to uh try to do the things um charge
fans um draw wash medium auto one okay yeah so if you do
well i cannot smash it oh my god earlier earlier earlier
okay gonna yeah ah wait wait earlier okay okay yeah sure
sure sure ah okay
oh oh yeah Oh my gosh, sorry.
Oh my god!
How am I not canceling it?
Oh, one second.
Wait, wait, wait.
There.
Trying to...
Am I canceling it wrong?
I just smacked... I'm just button smashing.
Yes.
Just smash it, smash it.
It's fine, it's fine.
Just...
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
The timing is right.
Yes!
Yep.
It also depends.
Okay.
If you want to do a jump and also the medium auto is fine.
So yeah.
Okay.
Just decide.
And also like one more thing.
Do try to do this one.
So.
Oh wait.
Whoops.
I'm on.
I forgot which what button it was.
Was the medium auto.
yeah oh yeah I guess like this so so if you do it well like
you try again okay
oh yeah let me try it yeah oops I didn't do double sorry
like you can you after I've killed my fans you keep smashing
okay like just smash your auto yes smash Oh, light auto,
okay.
Oh, I'm trying.
No, you block it first.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
So if you do well, like, your smashing will be punished.
Yeah.
Yep.
Just like this, like that.
Okay.
So this is a way to anti-give your opponent smashing.
but like this is not commonly used but like I think you're
going to try it you're smart you're really smart oh really
thank you I might not play Street Fighter at 9 but thank you
and and also yeah and also do do more this like do more this
I think it's a really good one and also you can decide like
you block it first block it first uh you block it block it
i'll block it yeah yeah you can decide whether walk up throw
but you can try it but the walk up for is not easy uh but
like is it need you in a closer range okay yep oh my god
because like the fans drop and also you jump so like there's
two things in the whole time your opponent will be scared oh
my my god okay yeah my mind is open uh and yeah i think yeah
yeah and also if you're in corner like just like this uh
like you stop stop oh sorry and so like if you're in this
range yeah like try to do uh like this one like yeah your
back one yeah and also like because like you try to do it i
don't think i have that button i don't have it okay another
i mean that the back back special back special back special
oh no just just oh this one yeah yeah yeah i've locked down
and you can charge fans oh so yep yep like this or maybe if
you cannot charge fan like just also do the like dash dash
throw do it whatever you want yeah yeah so it's just like
this but like like because it's really good move for poking
i think like if you don't know what to do because like um in
a range that um what i think charge fan is safe that is
because um when in this range your opponents can jump you
like if i charge fans your opponent can jump yeah like do
something so if in the far range your opponent cannot jump
like like this yeah like your opponent's barely cannot do
anything but like in those range if you cannot charge fans
like do the normal one normal fans um do this one okay it's
all this also work but like um but what that uh most usually
is in the far range just do your things dry wash and walk up
so so okay let's practice for more things so um you charge
fans so you mix with uh two um um charge fans dry wash
medium auto walk up pro okay okay
Throw.
Okay, I'm going to go.
Just press one and walk up.
Okay.
One time and walk up.
Because, yeah, it's hard to like.
Walk up, walk up.
Okay, okay.
Walk up.
It's supposed to...
Try again, try again.
No!
Okay.
I need to just walk up.
Don't!
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
I can do this.
all right yep i did it yeah what it should so you can mix
these two yeah yeah yeah or like in high level um you try to
confirm it like um if the opponents block it yeah like
because like uh um it just comes out uh so if the opponents
like for example if the opponents block your first crush
like the medium auto.
And if you don't, just only press one time for the second
medium auto.
If the opponent hit, like just press it again, like just
smash it.
So like, I mean, just like this.
If your opponent's hit, like just press it again.
Okay.
Like, this is weird.
Like, you need it in far range for this adapt.
Yeah, like far range too.
Yeah.
Oh, no!
I know it's hard, but this is not easy.
It's not!
No!
It's very hard.
I just want to mash it.
One, two.
There we go.
There you go.
the cat in my head one two oh no come on no okay I still hit
you though one two oh all right there you go one no whoops
well one go
like that yep yeah yeah yeah but like so you got like barely
a lot of options yeah stop it a bit stop it a bit okay like
can like dry wash throw dry wash overhead and also like this
one okay okay like you decide you a lot of tools so many
options charge fans oh my god like just barely uh reminding
that uh most useful like it's uh i think the lights uh light
auto is very good also for confirming uh okay okay so or
maybe in this way uh just forget those things progress the
the the medium one okay um do the charge fans dry rush uh
light auto yep but like you need to bear in mind in the
timing that um who beat my smash so try again ah so yeah
yeah yep like this yeah yep at least you can get something
yeah yeah and like yeah oh my gosh okay yeah it's not easy
but yeah there's too far oh no
yep yeah yeah and yeah dash of bro so like just remind like
so so let's be like clear a bit so so what you think we
should think it what you should think it is like this one
yeah this one and also this one okay and one more like just
another way um it's just used for if you like not using
driver you want to do something different yeah take your
meter and also you can get a good offense okay so yeah this
is also good good to use and also um like just make it
walkup pro and do a combo yep and also um and also in corner
like just try to throw more just remember throw more uh so
and one more things so um let's see so look because the
thing is um your auto combo if you've got no gauge you've
become like this right yeah um what's the three minutes so I
want you to do is that throw like in right timing like try
to throw it in right timing okay like okay okay not have a
medium start oh yeah yep yeah that's all good all right
again try again yep okay let's try again again again
No!
Yeah, earlier, earlier.
Earlier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should catch the timing.
Okay.
I need to dash, dash.
Okay, yeah, dash.
Yeah, dash.
Yeah.
No!
Earlier, earlier.
That need to be earlier.
Oh, sorry.
Because, like, you did it earlier, so you need to be a
little bit late.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right, like this, like this.
Alright, yeah.
It's okay, okay.
Sure, sure, sure.
I'm sorry.
I'm learning, I'm learning.
Easy, easy, easy.
Yep.
There we go.
Like this.
So, um, try to even, try to be late, even like...
Okay.
Be late.
Because you got, like, like, just don't be too early.
Yeah.
Because, like, if you be too early, your opponent tag it,
and you're too early, and he punish you.
Yeah.
your flow width okay so just a little bit late yep okay uh
what's what's that yeah i think until here a lot of things
like i need to yeah that's a lot of things you need to adapt
it there's so so much things i will just feel like it's feel
like a lesson the professor teach you whole things in one
day my tournament tomorrow yeah it's like we're cramming
yeah like yeah yeah step by step yeah yeah yeah we can do
this okay i will learn i will use all the
information it's all right my tournament's in less than 24
hours guys it's gonna be fine
yes guys the tournament is tomorrow we'll be okay
you find me for just one day practicing you know when i
realize that i just i don't know it'll be okay it'll like
it'll be okay it'll be okay i can it will fit in my head i
believe in myself and also i believe in your talents yeah
yeah yeah you can learn that you can learn it i can speed
right all right let's see i can remember all of this
Alright, there's this.
And then...
Oh, alright.
Oh, I'm fighting Viper.
Okay, that's good.
I'm fighting my future opponent.
Okay,
okay, okay, okay.
Oh, no.
I had to jump.
Oh my god, okay.
I did not expect the drive rush.
Right off the bat.
Oh my god, she's doing a lot of combos.
Okay, here we go.
Oh.
Okay.
What?
She's on the other side?
Yeah, this character is flying.
Okay.
It's okay.
I'm just letting the new information sit in my head for a
little bit.
yep oh no
yes yes
oh i thought oh no no no no no no no no okay
she jumps so much and i don't expect it oh oh my god this is
not like looking good.
No!
I was going to do that.
But I blocked her first.
Oh, come on.
Don't don't make me wait.
Don't make me wait.
She does it first.
Okay, okay.
No!
Her combos is crazy.
Yeah.
She knows more combos than me.
What?
Oh, I did.
I thought I had level one for some reason.
That's my bet.
Go.
Oh.
I mean, I'll take it.
Oh, fuck.
He throws me.
What?
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I throw.
I throw.
No, I couldn't throw because...
No, he blocked it!
Okay, nice.
Too good, too good.
Okay.
What?
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, of course.
Of course.
Jump, jump, jump.
I escaped it.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, but...
I'm a little scared.
I'm a little...
Oh, she said.
I'm no longer scared.
Oh,
I thought she was gonna...
Nice, nice, nice guessing.
I thought she was gonna do it.
Because she did it every other time!
Oh, nice.
Oh, I thought...
Oh my god, bitch.
Okay, good.
I...
Okay, it's fine.
You block his like...
I don't know.
Staffing that's so hard.
Yeah, yeah.
Ah.
Your crowd should block it.
You know, stand for me.
Yeah.
I just don't...
Sometimes I just...
I don't predict it correctly when he's gonna do it.
So it's like...
You can try to jump it if you're saying you teach to do it.
Oh, no!
No!
It's guess.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
He plays it a little bit.
He plays it a little bit late.
Oh, did I?
Oh, that's why.
I thought I matched it.
I guess not.
I guess I need to match it harder.
I mean, you can see her auto comfort is very good.
Yeah.
Very strong, like very good damage.
It is.
It threw me off.
Yeah, yeah.
Take it easy.
Okay.
You learn it later.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yep, yep, yep.
Wait, I feel like everyone uses this...
Oh, shit.
I got distracted.
No.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Go.
Oh, she threw me?
Okay.
Yay.
Oh my god, we both.
Okay.
Oh, he's fine.
Okay, okay.
No!
I already threw my fan!
It's okay.
They both burn out.
Yeah.
Try to try to catch a punch.
Yes!
Alright.
That was a risky play.
Round two.
Fight.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Nope.
I did not mean to.
I'll do it.
I'll take this.
Wait.
No, I already used my combo.
This is scary.
Oh, very good guys.
All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
He really didn't want me to go close to him.
Oh my god.
Just jump, jump more.
Jump more?
All right.
Go offense and jump.
No!
Ah!
He used the eye!
Oh my gosh.
oh now he jumps away I'm goodbye all right all right now I
just I just see a jump for it okay no
nice I got it I got it before I got it before I I matched it
first yep yep oh my god whoops that was an accident I was
trying to dash
Oh my god.
It's how they feel to fight me.
Oh, not good for me though.
It's my turn.
Impact, impact, impact.
Okay.
That is fine.
He didn't block it.
It's okay.
Oh.
No, I clicked it!
Yep.
Again, again, again.
Okay.
No.
No, I clicked.
Wait, wait.
Good.
Okay.
That's fine.
What?
No!
No, he got the throw.
He got it.
We're doing great.
We're doing better, better.
Okay.
I have the little three too.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's fine.
No, that's not fine.
That's no longer fine.
Okay, okay.
Watch his jump.
There we go.
No!
Ah!
Oh, he blocked it.
Of course he was.
No!
Oh, wait.
I got it!
I...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I got it.
I'm getting...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Muscle memory.
Yes.
We're doing.
it no i thought she was good it was just prediction
no okay
no i thought she was gonna
whoops yeah something just keep aggressive
the area of the impact oh
the knocks I should have expected that honestly no I thought
I could get the level 2 or level 1
okay no
I didn't mean to do that no yes no no no no no no no I think
oh no I don't get it I think that yeah yeah Very good.
Oh.
Nice.
Remember?
Try to throw more.
Yeah.
I just need to throw more.
Throw more.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I wanted to throw that but that was my bad.
I think I'm dead here.
Oh,
he knows I want to throw.
I didn't... I pressed once!
Alright.
No, I'm dead.
I didn't have Drive Impact.
No!
I need to throw more.
Pull more.
Charge more.
Throw more, charge more.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like we have a plan.
But like, because it's very weird, weird matchup.
Yeah.
Like, yeah.
Just need to throw more.
Like, if you think your opponents will react, like just
jump.
Mm-mm.
React your flow, jump.
Jump.
Oh my god, not her again.
I bet you it's the same person too.
Oh, no, it's different.
We actually don't remember.
Round one.
okay oh what the fuck what the fuck how am i how do i block
this stand stand block stand okay okay okay oh no oh no
she's just there's so many combos i feel like she's faster
didn't need ignore it ignore okay good oh no uh she's so
tall once you charge like don't be afraid we just dash
especially you got a far stop you got four plus all right
you get a far stop
up dash out and go ah she jumped she jumped too oh she's so
tall i keep thinking you'll be okay okay okay okay
oh no okay okay okay that's fine it's fine oh okay we're
fine we're fine rock it no I was I heard block but I already
started my movement He jumped quite a lot So yeah Okay Yes I
got oh fuck God I keep thinking she's doing a low Because
she's so tall
Yes She's so tall!
Like, yeah.
Alright.
Okay, and then she's gonna...
Yeah.
When can I attack?
Okay.
Alright.
He's late.
Yeah.
Are you gonna press it in the middle?
I can press it here.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yes.
Grab!
No, I couldn't grab.
No grab for me.
You do the reversal.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Oh, I'm lucky.
Grab!
Okay, let's go.
We're doing it!
We grabbed!
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
You're getting better.
Getting better.
Oh, my God.
She mixed it up, though.
Oh, no, I wanted to...
I was about to do the anti.
There you go.
Yes.
Okay.
Grab.
Throw a fence.
There you go.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to throw a fence.
I really am.
Okay.
Here we go.
Grab!
Oh, fuck.
Not grab.
No grab.
Oh, no grab.
It's fine.
I didn't want to grab anyway.
yes grab oh okay watch the oh no oh okay okay grab yeah okay
let's go yeah I grabbed I'm doing it are you I'm proud of
me.
I'm grabbing.
Yeah.
Way better than the first game.
Let's get improvement.
Yeah.
We're actually improving.
I'm cooking now.
Help me down.
Oh, kid.
Someone's internet's bad.
I know it's not me.
We're both in a...
Oh, no.
I'm gonna get my ass kicked by a gold player.
Gotcha.
My turn.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
But what if...
This guy's internet is so bad.
It's so bad.
I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
It's not me and I know.
Oh my god how is he playing?
How are you playing?
How is he playing?
Who is this internet?
They are cheating!
Okay, this guy is cheating.
I will plug.
I will.
I will plug if I have to.
There's no way he is playing as shitty of internet as I am
right now.
Okay.
Just want to guarantee this.
Oh, no.
I don't guarantee it.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, fuck.
No.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh my god!
What?
Why?
I refuse to do that.
to believe he's playing at the same lag as I am.
What is this?
No.
No, no, I wanted to, I was trying to do...
No, that's bad.
Was he landing me or he?
Yes, he does.
No!
Ah!
Oh my god, he fucked up.
He fucked up.
Oh my god, you can't.
You what?
Wait, he missed it.
Oh, okay, we win.
We win.
Okay, let's go.
Quit it.
I'm quitting.
No, we're not playing it.
Okay, we can go to the Bergamer setting.
Okay, we just set it.
No, I quit it in time.
Oh, say no.
Say no.
No!
Oh!
Oh no.
Sweating noob 2113.
Okay, he's not Wi-Fi though.
That's good.
Yes.
Oh.
Oh, my turn to get...
Oh, I did not mean to double mash that.
Wait, he messed up.
He messed up.
Nice.
Draw a shoulder, perhaps.
Try to do something like this.
Oh, never mind.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh.
I mean, I'll take it.
Oh, no, I was trying to do a dry hit.
Yeah.
There you go.
Okay, okay, okay.
No!
Oh.
It's fine.
Oh no, that's not good.
Yes.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
Ah, all right.
If you can react it, just rock it.
At least you won't get hit.
Okay.
Getting a gauge back.
okay try to like throw less oh throw less okay well throw
less like try to throw less only one and just throw more
charge plant more thought okay yeah okay oh i did not mean
to do that i actually i smashed square it was an accident it
was an accident no no well he knows i know he knows i can't
his things oh
my god he wouldn't let me grab him anymore
okay oh he's got me though
okay no no no he gets me all right it's fine Okay, okay.
It's fine.
Oh my god, I didn't mean to...
No!
That was an accident!
No, I didn't mean to!
I...
I block it?
Yes!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, I did not mean to do that, but that's fine!
That's fine, it's fine.
No!
Okay.
Forward, go forward, go forward.
I'm trying to!
Okay, okay.
No, no.
Wait, we're still alive.
We're still alive.
No!
Ah!
He tried.
I was gonna jump.
I was debating about jumping.
I hesitated.
I wanted to jump.
Oh, fuck.
I need not let him do that to the...
meat oh it's fine it's no longer fine it's not a fine what
oh my god fuck i
gave him that i hope you enjoy plight
No.
He knows how I play.
He's adapted to me.
I think you use a lot of five or just jump.
There you go.
No.
What are these moves?
He's using new moves.
He's mixed up.
He's mixing me up.
What the fuck?
He deserves this one.
He deserves to be in flat.
The big stuff!
So let's make it.
Stop it.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Then you just switch the settings, the rank settings.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The static connections to 4 to 5.
Okay.
3 to 5 is also fine.
So, let's make it this way.
are so when um you're getting closer to your opponents like
your opponents keep at attacking try your best to escape it
and do your plan do your things yeah okay just think how you
escape it do you only do yourself your things okay you
understand what i mean like always like just try to try to
escape yeah do do these buttons yeah or jump over them yeah
when you get a chance like just charge fans do your things
okay um yeah just don't be panic when you see like some
weird move all right i'll try not to panic that's really
hard but i'll try not to panic it's really hard
Okay.
All right.
All
right.
Oh, fuck you.
Ah.
Yeah.
Okay.
I didn't think I would hit that legitimately.
I thought...
Oh.
Are you kidding me?
You jump now?
yeah I oh my god she jumps when I don't expect it
okay okay okay no okay
I know she does that yeah yeah
all right Oh No, they have time to Do more back special if
you want to play in this ring.
Okay.
Oh, I tried to do it, but she did it back to me.
Whoops
Okay Ah, stupid jump What I oh It's fine.
I kill her.
Oh, I just don't have my thing anymore.
She has her infinite meter.
Her infinite shot.
She has her levels three, but I don't.
I don't.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't think I'd hit it.
I dropped the combo.
Oh That was I better mash that accidentally Yeah, try to
jump more I think Oh
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, yes, he had this Let's go,
let's go.
Yes, yes, yes, okay.
All right.
Let's go.
Nice dodge.
I didn't even know how I did that.
Something good.
Yes, yes.
Okay.
Oh.
He tagged.
No.
Oh.
Wait.
There you go I might No Jump I've tried to jump My turn
Confirmed My turn
Alright Jesus Christ
Jump more.
You can.
I did it!
I jumped!
Okay.
Oh, no.
I mean, do that.
Oh,
now she knows.
Oh.
Ah.
No one hit.
Go ahead.
Did I dodge?
No!
I couldn't!
I couldn't get out!
I already jumped!
She got me while jumping!
I was already jumping!
Oh,
I want it to...
Oh god.
Okay, good.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Jesus Christ!
Oh wait Oh, I should have done level 3 I should have done
level 3 I panicked No!
Oh, wait Wait, wait, wait Yes!
Oh god, okay We still got it We still got it We still got it
Okay, that's fine That's fine Okay, so Okay, let's try one
more thing Okay So Uh You can try to do more Um like only
press one time like just do the heavy pun heavy auto into
the special okay so like you save kind of save a little bit
later yeah maybe auto and then oh yeah yeah we only expect
yeah before yeah and also when you anti-air like your dp
anti-air and dash up and throw like just take your set uh
your opponent's jump so and then dash up uh roll just dash
up and throw okay dash up throw after entire okay all right
just make it mix it with dash up throw and also like charge
friends so this and then yeah oh oh my gosh any time it
correctly ah there you go yeah Like this.
Okay.
So yeah.
All right.
And also like, yeah, just do like you saying if she attack
or just jump.
Okay.
All right.
I got it.
I understand.
Yeah.
Don't do you if you want.
All right.
Okay, I'll do.
time is it now okay i'll do one more last game all right all
right last game
i believe just try your best to escape and charge charge
more fans okay let's go i
mean panicking is very like common yeah yeah everybody
panicked but like the plans uh-huh panic but also press
buttons yeah our best is to don't be scared if you can like
just walk for it even though you're not in good situations
uh-huh or maybe like you can press more only the medium
medium one medium button okay no not auto like just only
medium just medium okay just medium all right it's also a
good talk move low reward but like far range yeah oh oh
please sir please let me rank up okay so cool
yes oh okay so okay so this guy dp this guy dp there so now
we know Whoa.
Dash, go.
Oh my gosh.
Yes.
Oh, he changed, he mixed it up.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
Oh, I didn't mean it.
Okay, okay.
Walk forward.
Oh, he'll be scared.
Press your button.
Heavy.
He got hit.
Yeah.
Looking for impact.
No!
Of course he would do that!
He dropped down!
He got scared.
Are you scared?
If you're only looking for impact, just jump.
Okay.
You can escape it.
But only for right now.
Yeah.
All right.
No!
I was trying to do the circle.
Fortunate.
Yeah.
I don't...
No!
I hit it!
I'm so far though!
Okay, okay, it's fine, fine.
Okay.
It's very fine.
Get up the gauge back.
Okay, okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
He perfect buried me!
He doesn't want me to rank up.
He really doesn't want me to rank up.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Broke it.
Yes.
What do I do now?
Trust friend.
Throw.
Try to find a way to throw it.
Oh, I couldn't throw him.
He really doesn't want me to win.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's go.
If you think she attacked, just jump.
Ah.
I didn't see you.
Okay.
No, I thought he was gonna...
I thought he was gonna do the...
Okay, okay.
Nice.
Jump.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
No.
Oh!
Yeah, no!
You
know that.
Oh!
No!
Yes!
Okay, okay, okay.
Last kill, last kill.
That was last kill.
Yeah, that worked!
We did it!
We got back left too!
I panicked, but I pressed buttons!
I think I learned a lot.
You should have a girl waiting.
Like, you got a lot of...
Lots of things to learn.
So it's hard.
Yeah.
Do your best.
Thank you.
Do you think I can do it?
Coach?
Yeah, I think you can do it.
I think you can do it.
Nice.
We did it.
You learned a lot of playing in the league this week.
Yeah.
This game is very hard.
But like, yeah.
I'll get something at least.
I hope I win one round.
I...
It's okay, you believe in me, that's all that matters.
As long as you believe in me, it'll be fine.
I think I learned to throw more and to use my resource less.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that's all that matters.
There is a lot of pattern for attacking, but yeah.
Just try to do best, yeah.
Yeah, and I countered DI at least one time and that's an
account yeah yeah i did one counter di i think maybe three
just like muscle memory like you got a little bit time to
just spend like 35 minutes into training we're just looking
for yeah okay okay for the driving backs so yeah i just
needed yeah i got some counter di's in there i just gotta
get more and then and then i'll be unstoppable thank you
Thank you for the coaching session.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Thank you for giving your time.
Chad, say thank you to Mickey for coaching me on the last
day.
On the last day.
Surely this will be what I need.
This will be why I need to upgrade.
Thank you again, Mickey.
I really appreciate it.
uh ggs ggs thank you bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
chat bye by chat thank you so much we did it guys i i he
believes in me the one of the best my players in the world
believes in me and he was not trying to be nice about it i
say as i cope I say as I cope he believes I'm throwing more
yeah he believes in me more than shine ever did as long as
one coach believes in me he was very serious he was a very
serious I want to say mad but he's not even 18 yet he's He's
a very serious boy.
Yeah, while the shade on shine deserves it.
He's a very serious child.
Yeah, for those who don't know, Mickey is 17 years old, and
he's already one of the best mod players in the world.
What am I doing with my life?
I'm only plat.
Please!
Mickey isn't even 18!
He learned modern for me, you're right!
The way I thought he was mid-20s.
Yeah, and he was playing, he was like, I've never played
modern before until today.
He was really like, this is the first time I learned modern
because I never touched modern before until today.
I'm like, I'm sorry, they learned modern for me Bro, this
guy has been playing since he was a guy I started playing
two years ago And I was like, playing is like a strong word
Yeah, anyway guys, let's Good luck, I might do customs later
tonight Because I fucked up my sleep schedule But what else
is, I will try and sleep before My Overwatch tournament
Which is, I still find it funny that the Overwatch
tournament is more like casual, but I make more of my, this
is passion.
This is me for, this is passion for the FGC.
I, I will, I will, it's so funny.
The, it's like, at like three, four, five, six, it's like
$500 difference for last place between Street Fighter and
Overwatch.
But I'm practicing more for Street Fighter than, than for
For Overwatch, I just booted up like a couple of games
because it takes me 10 minutes to it takes me like 7 to 10
minutes to find a game in rank.
I was like, I can't be bothered.
I literally boot up Street Fighter rank and I put put on
worldwide.
I don't care if you're one bar and then I get a match in
like 10 seconds.
I was just like, this is more efficient.
This is more efficient.
love of the game all right guys i have to go practice
overwatch now i did i was supposed to practice like
overwatch an hour guys like hey guys don't worry i'll be
there and there can you can i can i show up at 10 and
they're like sure are you like are you still showing up it's
like i'll be there 30 minutes i'm still in street fighter
right now uh classic fc gc tournament reward people giving
their all for a 20 dollar chipotle gift card mike they give
us a super chat thank you thank you but huge shout out again
to mickey for coaching me apparently i was like his he
doesn't really coach at all he just plays so i really
appreciate him coming in seeing what he got and trying to
make something trying to salvage it i i i really appreciate
it so you check out mickey this is his twitter if you guys
want to check him out i like how i advertise mickey but not
But we all know shine.
It's fine.
I'll also give shine a shout out to look It's cuz he shine
didn't believe in me.
So shine didn't get a shout out He didn't he didn't believe
in me so I didn't give him a Twitter shout out
Yeah, if he wants the Twitter shout out on stream he needs
to be more supportive it above me.
Apparently he had two XKO tournament.
I don't even know how the well their team did.
Daughters get nothing.
Alright.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
You sail from me.
Head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Thank you again for coming to my Street Fighter training It
was a very serious one because he is a very serious child
Who has won a lot who has had won a lot of tournaments, by
the way Look at his goddamn Wikipedia It's like I was
surprised he even coached me I was surprised he didn't speak
Cantonese I was trying to be like Everyone speak Cantonese
Yeah, check out his wiki Look at his look at his credentials
guys wow yeah Wikipedia article at 17 it was he was locked
in I saw that guy in I saw that guy in Capcom Cup man I was
like oh my god I was his first student I hope he's proud of
me yeah but anyway guys I'm gonna head off now bye bye Bye!